the original aim of Steve Jobs of whom
you'll all have heard of who was at the
time interestingly the chairman of Apple
they had a very interesting structure
there he was the chairman of Apple but
he wasn't the president he and awards
niak had started off the Apple to as
many of you know but they'd had to get
venture capital money in and the moment
you get the money men in they want a
board of directors and they want to
adults in charge and Steve Jobs was not
allowed to run Apple the money man at
the time I think the president was
called Mike Markkula and he basically
laid down the law I had two projects on
the go one of which was the Mac here's a
list of some more of the applications
what assurance camera is capable of
focusing these in on these I'm not quite
sure
let me just read some of them out I
should make clear that because this has
been upgraded over a period of 12 to 13
years there's been a lot more
applications on there that were not
originally available in 1984 this is
more or less the way it was left in the
late 90s but you can see here Mac Wright
was there originally Mac draw which I've
just done with you
Mac paint you could even get sort of
black and white brush strokes and
spatter effects and so on it's a very
very very early taste of what things
like Photoshop will be able to do for
you and so on let's wrap up this trip
down memory lane by saying yes it could
be used for serious creation of
documents if you look at the screen here
there's a folder called writing etc in
which my daughter's filed away all the
essays she had to write Roger as a
Cambridge but if you happened not to
have a hard disk or there was some other
essay that you'd backed up somewhere you
could of course always have saved it out
to floppy disk and then recover it and
do some more work on it just by
inserting the floppy disk let's see what
happens I hope this is the right one not
exactly fast disc reader making quite a
noise here we go then despite the fact
that the title of the flop
is more games it's actually got a couple
of my daughter's dissertations on it now
again I don't know if you can see with a
resolution of Shawn's camera that
actually at the top left of this icon
there is a familiar W to signify that
this is a Microsoft Word file and yes
the Macintosh did have a significant
enough segment of the market that it
really was worthwhile doing Microsoft
Word and even simple spreadsheets and
stuff like that for the Macintosh so
let's double click on her dissertation
and see what happens
patience is so essential with this
earthly stuff
notice this notice that comes up about
copyrights and so on that's in a very
clunky screen font I think that one is
Geneva there was three or four fonts for
titling your screen windows and so on
with names like Geneva Chicago New York
and so on but here we are look we're
inside Microsoft Word on the Macintosh
and you can see that this really is
meant to be times bold slider bars down
the side gosh those are radically new as
well here starts the essay the new
interest in Latin was by no means
confined solely to technical areas and
so on
so as I think I've already said you
could keep your essays either on your
hard disk if you ran out of space or you
wanted backup copies you could put them
on floppy disks in just the sort of way
we're used to if you add an attached
image writer printer on the serial port
at the back of this you could print out
hard copies
you've got the beginnings there of
everything you wanted and everything
that we take for granted today there's a
lovely story there in the early day is I
think the team of Microsoft were
reported to Bill Gates and showed that
showed him a prototype where they done
what they called Windows which is just a
set of tile blocks on a screen you could
open up as it were a window or an affix
screen but it was part of them a tiled
collage as it were there was no way they
could overlap and there's no way could
grab hold
move it to a new place on the screen and
gates just tell them to go away and
think again and he said to them very
memorably because he didn't like
mentioning the world he said it's gotta
be like it is on the Macintosh you've
got about to drag-drop kill him off take
him to the trash bin go away do it again